we found him
welcome back to the studio first of all
congratulations those results did go
your way and you are the 2023 Junior
chess champion how are you feeling right
now feels amazing you're going to have a
chance to play against all the greats of
the game Fabiano Wesley Hikaru feels
it's it's an amazing feeling okay
how important is that ticket to the U.S
Championship because we were talking
about it it's so difficult to make it
based on the rating right now with the
US Championship you have to be around
2700 to even hope that you're going to
make it how important it is for you to
meet those
greats of the game it was very important
that was the main purpose of coming here
like this tournament is very strong in
itself but I I came here to win this
tournament to play in that U.S
championship and you've said this at the
beginning there is no other place that
matters it's first place or nothing and
you prove that from the beginning to the
end through your fighting spirit
what would you say are things that
you're happy with after this event based
on your play and things that you could
improve in order to meet those grades in
good shape sure one thing I need to do
is start playing more openings for sure
like half of like two games like for
example against Brandon and uh Jason
they were just draws out of the opening
so I need to diversify my openings
and also I feel that some games like
randomly like for example my games
against Kirk or like games against my
games against Kirk or Josiah like these
randomly I have these sort of off days
where I just play absolutely terrible
chess
but what is your main attribute that
you're happy with living this tournament
I must be at least one I guess it's just
don't even in terrible positions like in
both of the games against Kirk and
Josiah I was playing terribly I had dead
lost positions and even then I managed
to hold them so I guess it's my my
ability to to defend here and I guess
yeah that's the that's the thing that
made all the difference in the end I
have compared to all the other
competitors I haven't lost a single game
resilience is absolutely key especially
when uh later in October when you will
be facing uh the players at the USS
championships I've been money
congratulations just an inspiring
performance guys any questions for our
champion I will just Echo our
congratulations as well Mishra well done
well done Bravo yeah congratulations
very much I do have one quick question
and that is uh for the US Championship
that you qualified how are you going to
prepare are you going to mostly study
like openings that you're gonna play
against your opponent or do you want to
maybe get more tournaments so you are
um you know not Rusty when you are
entering that competition
yeah so now I have another couple
tournaments lined up like as of now
another five days I'll be coming back
here for summer chess classic right
against all like 2600 plus opposition
after that I'm going to play in Spain
either some Spanish league so yeah I
have a I have another couple tournaments
before
uh the U.S championship
and do everything breaks like are you
gonna take like few days off to
celebrate to to kind of recharge not do
chess or due to chess non-stop yeah
probably I'll take some break after like
another two three days and then I'll go
back to preparing for the next event
well congratulations really fantastic
accomplishment thank you yeah well done
very well done as